Hi, my name is Jenny Kim. I'm a project manager here
at Udacity. And my job is basically to, basically to keep,
a whole bunch of different people and processes and resources organized
so that the courses are delivered on time. Including this course.
So, I'm going to tell you a little about my phone.
It's a new phone. I got it a couple weeks ago.
It's a, it's a a Nexus 5. The screen is awesome.
It's really pretty. It's really fun to touch and to use.
The one thing is I haven't actually made it a phone yet
because I don't have the little SIM card. I haven't had time
to go get that done, so I just use it on wi-fi
networks for the time being. So far my favorite app is Gmail.